I'm not going there to be Russia's
friend they're not our friend they
undermine us at every opportunity that
they have and you better believe I will
keep a clear eye on them and I will
continue to hold them accountable we
will continue to apply maximum pressure
and if confirmed I will promise you that
we would be shining a light on Russia
Kelly craft is an American businesswoman
and diplomat she was also a major donor
to president Trump's 2016 election
campaign and the Republican Party since
2017 she served as the US ambassador to
Canada in February President Trump
nominated her as void to the UN
replacing cosna key Haley who resigned
last year we spoke to Syria fast a
libertarian US presidential candidate
who thinks craft won't bring anything
new to the job the whole point of the
United Nations is to try to foster peace
and unfortunately we've seen that the
United States the current administration
and the past administration whether it
was Samantha Power's or nikki Haley and
now this new ambassador if chosen is not
going to be any different I strongly
feel that the president at heart wants
to get along with Russia I think it's
the whole you know the Muellers report
and all that stuff that's going on with
the supposed Russian interference you
know they have to give some sort of
front you know that they are against
Russia so I really don't know what to
expect anymore from this current
administration all I can say is that
she's gonna be no different than the
past two ambassadors that were there if
she's even chosen so they have an agenda
on their own and it's gonna happen with
her without having a seat in the United
Nations unfortunately
you